it is rare that a Chancellor and prime
minister so closely aligned long-time
friends firm political allies but Liz
truss and quasi-quarten's bold plan for
the economy has sent the markets into
shock and conservatives past and present
are angry this is a disastrous start for
the new government unfortunately and I
was personally hoping that they now do
well and start dealing with of the huge
number of big crises that they've got
the worst possible start for a new prime
minister new chancellor who have plunged
us into with a budget into a financial
crisis and with the Tory conference
Round the Corner we're clearly in a very
serious situation there's this quiet
among current MPS too I I think it's
very very risky uh I think it's a
massive challenge if you were looking
for a path through it all and all of
that adding up to something that
convinces the markets that this
government is acting in a fiscally
responsible Manner and has a credible
plan and at the moment uh there are
question marks over all of that and are
you going to be going to the Party
Conference
are not but don't read into that
anything around what happened on Friday
because it was a decision I took some
time ago Mel stride isn't the only name
to miss a Tory Party Conference saja
Javed Rishi sunak and David Davis have
all confirmed they won't be going
whatever their reason it sends a clear
message but what's most striking is the
mood among Tory MPS behind the scenes
here's a sample of some of the messages
I've been sent privately one says it is
utterly humiliating the bank of England
have had to step in another tech simply
that they're shell shocked and a third
says I thought boris's cabinet was a
worst in history this one might just
have beaten it
as the PM's allies rally why is the Bank
of England had to intervene Mr free
smoke
are you in control of the economy sir
the chancellor has underlined the
government's commitment to fiscal
discipline and there are some still
convinced he should hold his nerve my
message today is that the government are
right to see the main threat for the
year ahead as recession not inflation
because the good news is that all the
forecasters say inflation will come down
a lot next year and the sooner the
better
behind the scenes they're trying to
steady nerves but Liz truss and
quasi-quarting haven't been seen in
public for days and many are now
wondering if the chancellor can survive
this Ali fullsku Sky News Westminster